hey 42 here con men I'm sure you've
noticed are whether it's a
Nigerian prince promising you a king
ransom or a 42 year old plumber called
Brian from Scotland who's posing as a
nymph called Stephanie online to sell
bath water on eBay
[Music]
deliberately carnivas for their own gain
are universally reviled or are they
whilst it's true that the guts of most
fraudsters are heartily hated by the
masses there's an odd exception to this
rule the greatest of all con men are
given a free pass
weirdly Humanity has decided that being
bad is bad unless you're really really
good at being bad and then being bad is
really good
think Jordan Belford or Frank Abagnale
Jr these men are self-confessed Crooks
but they're almost universally respected
and even admired in recent years
Hollywood awarded both men its highest
Honor by giving them a full dicaprioing
but what have I told you there was
another con man with such unparalleled
skill he wouldn't even throw a bone to
the so-called Wolf of Wall Street he
story is so utterly ridiculous that if
Hollywood ever does tell it through the
medium of Leonardo DiCaprio of course
nobody will believe it during a career
of concentrated conning that spanned
more than three decades and using
nothing but wit charm and more
confidence than Donald Trump's eyebrows
this man somehow managed to buy a famous
football club take control of an
investment bank and gain the exclusive
rights to more than a trillion dollars
of minerals
along the way he fooled one of grissom's
most senior spymasters hired the
services of a former England Football
manager and bamboozles North Korea's
supreme leader
this is a truly outrageous story of
Russell King the despot of deception the
Emperor of embezzlement the prince of
pulling a fast one and perhaps the
greatest con man who ever lived
even as a young man there was something
a little bit different about Russell
King he was intelligent a smooth talker
charming and ruthlessly ambitious before
he'd hit 30 he'd secured the job of
chairman at a publishing company called
celebrity group Holdings and outwardly
at least he was the epitome of success
the kind of entrepreneur over-excited
tick-tockers make videos about whilst
posing in their dad's suit next to a
rented Lamborghini
King drove fast cars lived in expensive
apartments and ate in the finest
restaurants like a lot but away from the
public eye celebrity group Holdings was
in serious financial trouble as the
company's chairman it was King's job to
turn things around so what do you think
he did release a new magazine invest in
a flashy marketing campaign pay millions
to a slit consultancy firm to come up
with some buzzwords
nope King May well have considered these
options but ultimately he rejected all
of them in favor of something far
simpler and far more illegal
you see he was a proud owner of a whole
stable full of supercars and amongst
them was an Aston Martin zagato worth
well over a million pounds he could
simply have sold the vehicle but that
would have meant taking a huge hit on
the depreciation instead he drove it to
his mate's house parked it in his garage
and calmly placed a phone call to his
insurance company claiming the vehicle
had been stolen yet the scam was about
as sophisticated as Nicki Minaj's lyrics
Aston Martin's Aunt all like common even
in Posh neighborhoods after a brief
investigation the insurance company
found the car and uncovered several
other misdemeanors committed by King and
his Associates at celebrity group
Holdings the company was sued and King
went to prison
the most auspicious of start to the
career of the greatest fraudster in
history but prison taught the man who
would be con man king something
important cheat has never Prosper no
just kidding prison taught Russell that
he needed to be a lot more careful when
ripping people off in the future and as
we're about to see that proved to be a
very valuable lesson indeed
King's next major con came on the island
of Jersey where he and a business
associate started a new company called
Belgravia Financial Services Group
in trademark style it wasn't long before
King was living the high life he
traveled the world in private jets
stayed at lavish hotels and they've
images from the timer to be believed ate
far too much fancy food all on company
expenses of course
[Music]
unsurprisingly this Reckless spending
took its toll and pretty soon Belgravia
groups finances were less healthy than a
deep fried double battered chocolate dip
chocolate coated Twinkie and then things
got even worse when King's business
partner decided to unexpectedly die from
a sudden blood clot for most people the
death of a colleague is a sad Affair but
to Russell King it was an opportunity
with nobody around to stop him he stole
670 000 pounds from the company's
accounts and hightel the tough to
Bahrain before anyone noticed
by this point in our story Russell King
is still a fairly small time Croc but
that's about to change because it was in
Bahrain that he came up with an idea
that would put him on course to carry
out a con the likes of which the world
has never seen before in 2009 he
returned to the UK ready to put his new
scheme into action and it wasn't long
before he found a likely Target an
investment bank called first London
King's plan was simple he claimed to be
a representative of the Bahraini royal
family with five billion dollars at his
disposal to invest in promising
businesses
first London was a relatively small
player at the time and millions of
dollars of fresh investment was nothing
to be sniffed at they sent one of their
senior advisors a man called Sir John
Walker to evaluate King's proposal to
say that this was Russell's first real
test would be a bit of an understatement
Walker was a former Royal Air Force
officer and one-time director and
spymaster of possibly the most generic
sounding organization I've ever heard
defense intelligence part of the British
Ministry of Defense most con men would
have run a mile saved all her hair off
and emigrated to Mongolia at the mere
mention of his name butts as we're about
to find out King was not most con men
not only did he manage to gain Walker's
trust his and Bull story about
Bahraini billions proved so convincing
that first London gave King 49 of their
shares just to have a piece of it armed
with nothing more than sheer hutzpah
King had become the proud owner of half
an investment Bank
that in itself is absolutely insane but
King Khan was just getting started
fast forward a few months and he was
living it up in the impossibly lavish
Ritz Carlton Hotel in Bahrain with him
with several of his associates and the
delegation of senior figures from Notts
County football club
phase two of King's plan by a famous
football team was well underway
County we're in League two at the time
the lowest tier of the English football
league but make no mistake this is a
proud and storied football club the
oldest professional team in the world
and the reason the mighty Juventus play
in black and white stripes Juventus
borrowed some old nuts County shirts
back in 1903 and the rest is history in
short Notts County was a woolly mammoth
frozen in ice and Russell King turned up
with a big dodgy flamethrower billions
of Bahraini dollars yes I'm aware woolly
mammoth will be absolutely
football but it was a good metaphor to
help pull off the scam King went to
incredible Lems to ensure he and his
team looked apart the Ritz Carlton is
one of the fanciest hotels in the whole
of Bahrain and King spared no expense
whining and dining his guests he'd
prepared a business plan for the club's
future and PowerPoint presentations with
more slides than a water park what if
his associates even pretended to be a
Bahraini Prince a disguise that
apparently also filled the hotel's staff
who treated The Imposter with all the
respect they fought he deserved it was
an impressive show and the Knotts County
delegates were lapping it up as king
knew they would the timing was also apt
this was six years after Roman
abramovich's billions changed Chelsea's
fortunes and the year after another
Middle Eastern power took over
Manchester City
anyone who was anyone who happened to be
a historic English football club was
receiving cash injections and Knott's
County had been mired in financial
difficulty for years so getting their
own Middle Eastern money vaccine could
protect them from bankruptcy
[Music]
still these men weren't idiots the
potential sale of the club was a big
deal literally and there were certain
processes and procedures that needed to
be followed King clearly talked a good
game but the county delegates needed
proof that he wasn't all Guff and no
gold to your average everyday con man
such a request would have been a
disaster after all those Bahraini
billions King kept banging on about were
like Mark Zuckerberg's emotions they
didn't actually exist but it turns out
owning a 50 share in an investment Bank
comes in pretty handy when you're a
fraudster faster than you could say what
a bunch of silly Bankers he produced a
formal guarantee to the tune of five
million pounds confirming that first
London Investment Bank would underwrite
the deal from that point on the not
County officials were in the palm of
King's chubby I mean grubby hands and
considering their dire Financial
straights they agreed to sell him the
entire football club for the princely
sum of one pound
it's worth pointing out here that there
are rules against convicted criminals
taking over football clubs but King was
always careful to mask his own
involvement in the deals he was rarely
the face of the operation and often
acted as a mere consultant of some shady
organization he'd set up so when the
football league Regulators came asking
questions he simply faded into the
background
he was so elusive that during his time
at Knotts County he adopted the nickname
Lord Voldemort in hindsight that
probably should have been a bit of a red
flag andalusive is exactly how Mr
Voldemort played things after his
takeover was complete his name wasn't on
any of the contracts and he didn't do
any interviews with the press all the
same everyone at Knox County football
club knew he was calling the shots and
boy did Russell King call some shots
within a matter of weeks he'd persuaded
former England manager svengar and
Eriksen to take up the role of director
of football of this lowly little club
which was like convincing Gordon Ramsay
to manage a Burger King in Slough but
King sold the Swede Vision he couldn't
resist and he gave him 9 million pounds
in shares in a company called Swiss
commodity Holdings which was King's
latest dodgy Venture so yeah that
probably helped as well
former Arsenal and England Defender Sol
Campbell with the next big signing
through the door and it seems as though
Kings promised to bring Knox County back
to the big time would soon be fulfilled
in the meantime King Was preparing to
carry out the final stage of his master
plan and what's a bloody weird planet
turned out to be over the years he'd
somehow managed to get himself contacts
in of all places North Korea
by late 2009 he was ready to put those
contacts to good use by buying the
Mining rights to all the gold iron ore
and coal in the entire country
if that sounds a little random
it absolutely was but once again King
had chosen his Target well since North
Korea has the international diplomacy
skills of an Internet troll and
threatens to Nuke the out of the
planet every second Sunday of the month
North Korea is one of the most
sanctioned countries on Earth it's also
one of the poorest
King knew only too well that supreme
leader Kim Jong-il couldn't afford to
actually mine any of the trillions of
dollars of valuable minerals hidden
beneath his country's surface so why not
sell them to King as a Job Lot for
several billion dollars
in November 2009 King flew to North
Korea to negotiate the deal and he
wasn't alone with him on the plane to
Pyongyang was fengor and Ericsson and
yet another fake Bahraini Prince it
should be clear by now how insanely
ambitious and just plain insane King
actually was because if his ruse was
uncovered by the North Koreans he was
risking far worse than jail time and you
might be wondering exactly why King
bothered bringing's Fen Along on this
mad Escapade but as always he had his
reasons if you happen to be a student of
the beautiful game all this talk of
North Korea football and the late
noughties might have triggered some
memories
cars less than a year after King Co flew
to Pyongyang North Korea made only their
second ever appearance at a World Cup
finals
the North Koreans wanted Sven to help
them with their preparations for the
prestigious tournament and according to
the man himself they even asked to abuse
his position on the FIFA football
committee to help them secure an easy
group King Sven and the rest of the
delegation were given an audience with
North Korea chairman Kim Yong Nam the
most senior figure in the entire country
after Kim Young Gil for obvious reasons
not a whole lot is known about this
meeting but by the time it concluded the
Mining rights to all the gold iron ore
and coal in North Korea were officially
signed over to King's new company Swiss
commodity holding
in Europe representatives of the company
were already exploring the possibility
of a stock market flotation
thanks to King's business in Pyongyang
they were claiming assets of 1.2
trillion dollars making Swiss commodity
holding one of the most valuable
companies on the entire planet
but it wouldn't hold that distinction
for very long amongst the many things
King promised the North Koreans as part
of the mining deal was a ship full of
Bahraini fuel whether or not that tanker
ever existed is unknown what is known is
that it never arrived and concerned
North Korean officials started asking
some very difficult questions it wasn't
long before the deal had unraveled
completely and King was forced to flee
the country in fear of his life
considering how well things have been
going up to this point it's easy to
forget something very important this
entire mad scheme was based on literally
nothing there had never been any cash
only promises and there's not County
soon found out promises don't pay the
bills from the Caterers to the cleaners
the players to the physios nobody at the
club was actually getting paid it was
the same story at first London the
promised Bahraini investment never
showed up and the company's directors
were beginning to realize they'd handed
over half their shares in return for the
square root a all
king tried to stall by claiming
International banking procedures were
slowing down the money coming in from
Bahrain the trouble was what was he
stalling for there was no money so what
did the inimitable King do is his
kingdom of cards came crashing down
around him what he always did of course
he book it off to Bahrain in fact he
spent the next few years in the Middle
East ripping people off in a series of
cons in the publishing industry
operating under various pseudonyms he
seems to have made a fair bit of money
too though nothing on the scale of his
nuts County and North Korea Shenanigans
but this time retreating to deepest
darkest Bahrain didn't allow King to
drop off the radar entirely he'd left
nuts County in financial ruin and first
London Investment Bank in administration
a lot of people were unsurprisingly
pretty damn cross in 2018 the
authorities finally caught up with him
and Russell King con man extraordinaire
was brought to Justice
[Music]
so just how much jail time do you get
for 30 years of deception and Untold
millions of dollars in Damages decades
centuries Millennia actually King was
sentenced to just six years behind bars
and he only served three of them what's
even more galling is that about half of
the time coincided with the covid
pandemic meaning King was in prison when
half the world was in lockdown anyway
at the start of this video I said that
the very best con men are respected and
often admired but I don't think that's
the case of Russell King at least not in
the UK you just don't with football
over here but it's hard to deny he did
some pretty incredible things in his
chosen field of ruining people's lives
nobody knows for sure just how
meticulously planned his grand scheme
really was
first he conned the bank which allowed
him to fool a football club which
enabled him to hire Sven who helped him
close the deal with North Korea it was
almost too perfect it may just be that
King was a very ballsy chancer who took
advantage of any opportunity that came
his way but if he truly did see all of
that coming
he really is the greatest con man who
ever lived
[Applause]
thanks for watching